welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host definition aka the guy
with a worm sign
the likes that god has never seen and
the first official trailer for june is
now out in cinemas
but if you haven't had the chance to
check it out yet because of what's going
on
then this is the video for you
throughout it we'll be going through the
ins and outs of the trailer
and giving our thoughts on the teaser as
a whole there will be some spoilers here
so if you want some surprises left for
when it releases online on the 9th of
september
then i recommend that you go off-world
as fast as you can
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos that will spice up your life
every day
and don't forget to hit the thumbs up
button if you enjoy it
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the breakdown
okay so unfortunately when i went to see
tennant yesterday
there were absolutely no trailers at the
start of the movie and it just kicked
off with the opening of the film as soon
as the lights dimmed
however this description comes from a
canadian cinema employee who not only
posted an entire write-up of the trailer
but also showed some images of it we
combat them in here because of copyright
reasons
and the last time that i did this
ironically with the theatrical trail of
a tenet
my video got blocked and the channel
received a strike however
i have seen some of the images that were
posted and they do line up a lot with
what's here
so it seems all legit in a book board
i've taken that description and flesh it
out with some extra info though
so you know what to expect going in now
as for the trailer itself
it opens with a gorgeous custom wb
and legendary logo the two of which are
golden black
it looks like warner brothers are now
doing basically custom colors across the
board for their films
as we saw in the opening of the batman
trailer that the warner brothers logo
was red and black
and at the beginning of tennis it was
actually a very dark red
now this was the first bit of info that
really tipped the scales for me for this
being a real description
as a doubt anyone would have noticed
that warner brothers have started doing
this
unless they've seen not only the batman
trailer but also tennis itself
the trailer then cuts right into an
iconic scene from the novel
that fans will immediately recognize
that is the gomjabot test
this scene takes place early on in the
novel and it's actually the focal point
of this teaser
now in case you don't know the gomja bar
is basically a test of humanity
that's used to determine whether someone
possesses it or not
this involves the person being tested
putting their hand inside a box that
causes overwhelming pain
and at their neck is placed a poisonous
needle so that they cannot black out of
it
we actually see this in the trailer and
before traveling to arrakis
paul artradies is introduced to the
reverend mother gaius helen maheim
this was actually shown in the 1984 film
and similar that the character asks paul
to place his hand inside a box
which burns away at it the employee who
wrote the description
said that the scene was nothing short of
stunning from a purely visual
perspective
this has me hyped as all the images
we've seen so far
make the film look absolutely fantastic
and i really can't wait to see it in
action
the set that paul and the reverend
mother sit in is enormous and circular
with beautifully ornate carvings in the
walls and floors
sunlight beams through a skylight and
the two characters are centered in the
room
the reverend mother is wearing a complex
gown that's almost terrifying
and the black netted materials drape
over her entire body
she speaks with a taunting almost
mechanical tone
explaining the test to pool the author
of the description then said that paul
could tell he was clearly in
over his head and that he started
trembling as the test began
as the test plays out and his fear and
pain increases
the footage is in to cut with sweeping
shots of arrakis deep desert
with dunes as far as the eye can see the
author
says it's exactly how you would imagine
it and it catches the book perfectly
the entire landscape is bright yellow
and you can feel the sun through the
screen
we also get quick big shots of almost
every cast member
making their faces obvious to the
viewers from here we see a door open on
an aircraft
and the arthritis men stand in their
armor as the arrakis sun shines on them
oscar isaacs looks absolutely regal and
badass as duka tradies
rebecca ferguson is hooded and smiling
as lady jessica
and duncan idaho played by jason mamoa
makes a quick appearance wearing a still
suit
you also see javier bardem stillgar
remove his face
and mask to speak to someone the montage
continues with zendaya's character
climbing over rocks with a group of
three men some quick shots
also include an ornithopter touching
down in the desert and paul stepping off
of it
from here we see chang chen as dr
wellington yu
sharon duncan brewster as lead kinds and
our first look at the beast is then
dropped
dave bautista who's playing the
character looks almost painted white
or covered in dust and the actor really
embodies the character brilliantly
there's also the quickest glimpse of a
character's head emerging from a huge
tube full of liquid
that had a similar colour to rabban's
skin the characters seem to be baron
vladimir
played by stellen sarsgaard and the
moment is meant to be extremely
grotesque
throughout the teaser the intensity of
paul's test builds and builds
with each new cast member who's
introduced this finally culminates with
an epic close-up of paul in the desert
in a still suit walking amongst the
freemen the score really comes in as the
title reveals itself
and the user said that it sounded very
hands in my-esque
it sounds like a cross between blade
runner and the lion king
that perfectly captured the tone of the
movie due to its drums and ethereal
strings
the users stated that the trailer lasted
only about 90 seconds
however it was an incredible journey
that instantly let the viewer know
that this was the adaptation we'd all
been waiting for that's pretty much the
trailer in a nutshell
and before we get into my thoughts i
just want to let you know we're giving
away a free copy of marvel's avengers to
one random subscriber
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning the game is like the video
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the teaser in the comment
section below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of august and the set
will be shipped out from then to over
against the prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part
okay so as i'm sure you can guess i'm
really excited to see what goes down in
the film
and this trailer sounds absolutely
phenomenal the gamja bar test is one of
the most memorable scenes not only in
the book
but also the film itself i think it's so
smart to set an entire trailer around
this
whilst we cut in between the characters
and see them introduced
all while showing how strong that paul
is our direction is also something that
you really need to nail when it comes to
june
and from the first stills that we saw i
knew the creative team had really put a
lot of effort and thought into capturing
the look of the film
and how the book should be translated to
screen i'm definitely in the mind state
that this is gonna be one of the best
movies of the year and let's be honest
not much competition
but i think even if it gets released
next year then
yeah probably still gonna be one of the
best now that does bring us on to our
next subject
which is whether the film will actually
meet its release date or not
personally i think that it will and the
fact that warner brothers are promoting
it
makes me confident that it will see the
light of day in the darkest month of the
year
which just so happens to be taking place
in probably
the darkest year of the darkest timeline
but how do i know this
well i actually speak to a lot of
insiders who are parts of pr teams
and the marketing departments at studios
from what i've heard
every studio has basically been waiting
to see how tenet will perform
and then if it does well they will
release their movies
this is across the board and it also
involves black widow 2
which disney are holding back on in
order to see how christopher nolan's
movie does
if it underperforms then they'll likely
release it on disney plus
similar to mulan however it doesn't seem
like they're going to need to
tenet was originally predicted to do 40
million this entire weekend
however in its first day the pre-sale
tickets have already outperformed
dunkirk
which made 50 million so it does seem
likely that it will in fact perform
above its expectations
and this sets a good precedent for june
being released on schedule
we still have to see how things go ahead
over the saturday and sunday
but i can see tenet performing really
well and i'm even going to see it myself
a second time today so yeah i'm helping
out too now we will likely get more
clarity when the trailer is released on
the 9th of september
and hopefully it comes with a release
date so we can see when the film
actually will drop in cinemas
anyway that's our entire video and
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the tea set so make sure you comment
below and let me know if you're as hyped
for it as we are then drop a thumbs up
and if you want something else to watch
then make sure you check out our
breakdown of tinnette
which is going to be linked at the end
we go over everything that you need to
know about the movie
and it's ending so it's definitely worth
checking out after this
if you want to support the channel and
get see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat us on the discord
server linked in the description
or heavy swirlers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next time
take care peace
you